Modern horror movies often go overlooked,
but from time to time, a spectacularly terrifying
film takes the public by storm.
Perhaps 2017 is the year that happens again,
and any number of the following horror movies
could do it.
Here are all of the horror movies that will
blow everyone away in 2017.
Split
This could be the year that M. Night Shyamalan's
career experiences a renaissance, and after
flops like The Last Airbender, he really needs
it.
His latest film, Split, is loosely inspired
by the true story of Billy Milligan, the first
person to be acquitted of a major crime because
of his multiple personality disorder.
Filmmakers have been trying to bring Milligan's
story to life on the big screen for years,
and now Shyamalan is making it happen.
James McAvoy, still bald from X-Men: Apocalypse,
stars as Kevin, who suffers from dissociative
identity disorder, in what could be a long
awaited return to form for Shyamalan.
Resident Evil: The Final Chapter
Milla Jovovich is back for the long-awaited,
final installment in the Resident Evil movie
series.
Despite falling victim to the video game movie
curse, the franchise continues to turn a profit
and will likely do so again with Resident
Evil: The Final Chapter.
In this ultimate installment, releasing in
late January, Alice and her band of survivors
will make their final stand against the Umbrella
Corporation and the undead in the dreaded
Raccoon City.
We're five movies and over twenty games deep,
so why stop now?
Rings
Over a decade after The Ring Two was released
in theaters…
"Mommy!"
"I'm not your ----ing mommy!"
….Paramount is bringing it back for a third
installment, simply titled Rings, which takes
place 13 years after the events of the first
movie.
Since VHS isn't really a thing anymore, it's
now a digital video that'll kill you in seven
days, which is pretty much the worst computer
virus ever.
"Do you want to destroy humans?
Please say no."
"Ok, I will destroy humans."
"Noo I take it back!
Don't destroy humans."
The twist?
There's a part of the deadly video that no
one's seen until now, so expect completely
new levels of chaos and even more drippy horror
children on February 3rd.
A Cure for Wellness
You might not expect a horror movie from the
guy who directed Rango, but Gore Verbinski
is going back to his horror roots with his
next film, A Cure for Wellness.
On February 17th, he's turning the tables
and making a psychological horror starring
Dane DeHaan and the naturally terrifying Mia
Goth.
The film follows DeHaan's Mr. Lockhart as
he attempts to retrieve his company's CEO
and escape from a mysterious wellness center
in the Swiss Alps.
Of course, this isn't a feel-good film about
getting one's groove back, and the wellness
center doesn't really have its customers'
best interests at heart, so psychological
terror ensues.
Get Out
"Get out."
"Sorry man."
"Get out!"
"Yo!"
"Aaahhh!"
Marking the directorial debut of comedian
Jordan Peele, best known for Comedy Central's
Key & Peele, Get Out follows an interracial
couple as they visit a town where black residents
have begun to go missing.
Starring Daniel Kaluuya, Allison Williams,
Catherine Keener, and Erika Alexander, Get
Out is being produced by Blumhouse Productions,
who rarely makes bad horror movies.
Just look at their slate: Paranormal Activity,
Insidious, The Purge, and Sinister are just
some of their iconic films.
Moving from comedy acting to horror directing
is a big leap, but early buzz surrounding
this film's February 24th release is all positive.
Personal Shopper
Though she'll always be best known as Twilight's
Bella Swan, Kristen Stewart continues to make
a name for herself in numerous independent
films.
Next up is the French-made psychological thriller
Personal Shopper, which follows Stewart as
Maureen, who's employed as a personal shopper
for a German model.
The twist?
When she's not buying stuff for pretty people,
she's trying to contact her dead brother,
Lewis.
Where those two things meet is anyone's guess,
but surprisingly, the film earned the Best
Director award at the 2016 Cannes Film Festival.
The film gets a wide release on March 10th.
Alien: Covenant
Featuring the return of Michael Fassbender,
and featuring Katherine Waterston, Billy Crudup,
and Danny McBride, director Ridley Scott is
finally bringing his Prometheus sequel, Alien:
Covenant, to theaters this year.
This isn't to be confused with a new Alien
film, stuck in development hell since 2002
and directed by Neill Blomkamp, which is supposedly
following later.
We're still in pre-Alien continuity here.
Although Scott's original idea was to explore
the mysteries left unanswered in Prometheus
with Noomi Rapace returning as Elizabeth Shaw,
things have taken a different turn.
Instead of directly following the events of
Prometheus, Alien: Covenant will follow a
new crew, aboard a new ship, whose path will
intersect with the survivors of the Prometheus.
Meet the new xenomorphs on May 19th.
The Mummy
Even Universal Pictures is climbing aboard
the cinematic universe train.
Since they don't have a catalog of comic book
properties they can sift through, they're
mounting their shared universe around the
iconic monsters that made them a worldwide
brand, beginning with Alex Kurtzman's The
Mummy on June 9th.
Starring Tom Cruise, Sofia Boutella, and Russell
Crowe as Dr. Henry Jekyll, The Mummy ignores
the delightful campiness of Brendan Fraser's
previous Mummy trilogy, and instead brings
the film back to its horror roots.
The new film also takes the franchise in a
new direction by setting it in the present
day and featuring a new mummy.
Taking down Imhotep three times was more than
enough.
Amityville: The Awakening
The June 30th release of Franck Khalfoun's
Amityville: The Awakening will mark the 18th
movie based on the haunted house since the
series' inception in 1979.
Each installment in the Amityville franchise
just adds to the weird continuity nightmare,
which has been plagued with prequels, pre-sequels,
and an occasional lawsuit.
(Hilariously bad chainsaw scene)
You probably know what to expect with the
new Amityville chapter: a single mother and
her three kids unknowingly move into the infamous
112 Ocean Avenue house, and terror ensues.
Worst realtor ever.
You should always put 'bleeding walls' in
the listing.
Some people might even like that kinda thing!
"Make the walls bleed!"
"No."
"Hey man we own you, let's see some blood!"
"I don't have to entertain you!"
"Come on man!
Do it!
Do the blood thing!
Come on, do it!
do it!
Annabelle 2
In 2013, The Conjuring surprised audiences
by effectively reinventing age-old scare tactics,
and was popular enough to warrant a spin-off.
That movie, Annabelle, focused on the origins
of the terror doll made famous by the original.
Now, Annabelle is becoming its own horror
series, because honestly, she's pretty freakin'
scary.
"Stop!
----!"
The new installment follows a nun and a group
of young girls who move into a dollmaker's
home.
And because it's a horror film, it's the same
hoouse in which the dollmaker's daughter died
20 years prior.
Annabelle finds a fresh set of new victims
on August 11th.
IT
Hollywood loves adapting Stephen King's works.
A miniseries based on the novel IT aired on
television in 1990, starring Tim Curry as
Pennywise.
But that just wasn't enough for fans of nightmare
clowns.
A cinematic version of IT is due to hit theaters
on September 8th, but because of production
challenges and a change in director, the production's
original star, Will Poulter, will no longer
be playing Pennywise.
His replacement, Bill Skarsgard, seems pretty
terrifying, but he's got some big, Tim Curry-sized
shoes to fill.
"Excuse me sir!
Do you have Prince Albert in a can?
You do?!
Well ya better let the poor guy out!
Woo ha!
Woo ha!"
Flatliners
Years before Joel Schumacher destroyed Batman...
...he brought Peter Filardi's science fiction
horror film, Flatliners, to the silver screen.
The film follows five medical students as
they voluntarily subject themselves to near-death
experiences in order to discover what lies
in the afterlife.
Now, 27 years later, a sequel is in the works,
also titled Flatliners, starring Ellen Page,
Diego Luna, and Nina Dobrev, with Kiefer Sutherland
returning from the original movie.
A plot summary hasn't been released yet, but
you can expect a whole lot of almost dying
— and maybe a little bit of actual dying
too — on September 29th.
Friday the 13th
Warner Bros. originally commissioned a Friday
the 13th sequel in 2009, but the studio canceled
the project before relinquishing the rights
to Paramount Pictures so they could co-produce
Christopher Nolan's Interstellar.
Fans were disappointed, but Paramount immediately
began working on their own Friday the 13th
movie.
According to reports, the new film will be
an origin story, featuring the return of Jason's
mother… and was reportedly almost some deranged
version of Dazed and Confused meets Jason.
As if this wasn't creepy enough.
"That's what I love about these high school
girls man.
I get older, they stay the same age ahahaha."
What's more, this will be the 13th installment
in the Friday the 13th franchise, which will
also release on Friday the 13th this October.
Insidious: Chapter 4
James Wan is truly the modern master of horror,
having created the Saw, Conjuring, and Insidious
franchises.
Today, he's directing things like Furious
7 and DC's upcoming Aquaman film.
But despite his exit from the Insidious franchise,
it continues to prosper, so much that FilmDistrict
ordered a fourth installment to be directed
by Adam Robitel and written by franchise co-creator
Leigh Whannell.
Not much is known about the film at this time,
except for its strategic October release date.
Saw: Legacy
When the Saw franchise began in 2004, one
installment was released every year until
2010…. and then nothing.
Now, seven years later, it's back for one
last chapter with Saw: Legacy, directed by
the Spierig Brothers.
So, why are they bringing Saw back after all
these years?
The filmmakers originally intended Saw 3D
to be the final installment in the long-running
franchise.
However, when Saw 6 underperformed at the
box office, Lionsgate approved one more movie,
which hindered the filmmakers' plans and left
the franchise with an unsatisfactory twist
and more questions than answers.
Saw: Legacy, releasing on October 27th, will
hopefully answer some of those lingering mysteries,
as well as reinvent the franchise.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!